first question for you this is your
first feature film in a little while so
I was wondering what inspired the choice
to stick with the series format for so
long is that a format that you find
especially creatively fulfilling or is
it more about you know the directions
that the industry winds blow you in I
think it's a little bit of both because
one thing that's nice about working on
series is that you could experience a
lot of different types of Storytelling
different genres so I think for just
filling your toolkit it's it's great and
there have been so many good shows in
the past few years that you know there's
ones where you just oh I can't pass up
that I can't pass up that so uh yeah I
feel like it's it's almost like you know
graduate school or something you've
worked on uh quite a few very very
special ones so of all the series you've
worked on recently which one did you
find influencing your approach to the
work on quiz lady the most oh gosh I had
not really thought thought about that I
mean I I would say that you know
certainly there's um anywhere where
there's comedy uh so for example a
little bit different but some years ago
I did an episode of Lady Dynamite with
Maria Bamford who makes a cameo and quiz
lady and there's something about like
the the Whimsical sort of goofy yes we
are going there nature of some of those
jokes that um I I
felt are akin to some of the um humor in
quiz lady where we just pushed things a
little bit I'll ask you the reverse of
that is there any show that you've
worked on in another genre that you
would most like to make a feature film
in oh um you know actually uh an
American Horror star was a a really fun
thing to go and like watch Rosemary's
Baby and all those creepy movies of that
era and try to figure out what creeps
you out and how um I very much enjoyed
that I was like oh yeah it'd be really
fun to do like a creepy
dread movie so yeah um that might be
that might be one that was the right
answer I like that come join us in the
horror genre please I I sold one
ticket I I will definitely I will buy
the ticket but I will encourage my
friends so I can guarantee you at least
like two or three tickets oh okay okay
you got like two or three friends
amazing all right so I want to talk a
little bit about your cast here because
I heard in another interview that you
Aquafina and S ra got to collaborate for
something like a year before filming
which is very unusual but also very very
exciting so what is something that
everyone can see in the finished film
that you know you can attribute to
having that extra time together oh yeah
oh okay so I don't know are we in like
spoiler territory there's a a
traumatic um there's a traumatic U
memory that the sisters have that
involves digging a hole in the yard um
that is straight out of aquafina's um
mind
and perhaps experience I don't want to
like out her on that if that's not uh
actually factual but um it was something
you know somebody like blurts out
something in the room we're all laughing
and then we're thinking but could it be
that it's that kind of moment I will put
the spoiler warning up for this and cut
it out and save it for the appropriate
time but I have to follow up on that can
you kind of walk us through whatever day
that you were having that conversation
where she just randomly suggested that
of all things yes okay so we're in
London I was working there Sandra was
working there Aquafina came to join us
Jen D'Angelo our screenwriter so we're
we're sitting around talking about the
idea of childhood trauma right and how
something that can seem small and absurd
is like for everybody else it's like the
Titanic right when you think about it in
family terms and so so Aquafina was like
yeah you know like I don't like having
being embarrassed about going to the
bathroom and then like you you know I
don't know you like dig a hole and and
then someone finds it in the yard and we
were like what what what was that and um
again I cannot say for sure that that is
actually something that that that that
happened but it was that idea um that
that could be the most humiliating and
um and just third rail memory in this
family so that when they argue about it
they're not laughing about it even if we
are because to them it's you know that's
that's horrible yeah it plays so well in
the movie I couldn't believe it when he
like came out of the blue and then I'm
like oh no this actually works and
serves the story quite well yeah yeah
there's a ring of Truth in there I you
know and then so of course then we're
all sharing our humiliating uh memories
and you know Code of Silence kind of
thing but yeah it was uh it takes a 2
and 11 for sure but I have to imagine
that literally every person on this
planet has had the fear of clogging a
toilet in a strange home oh yeah yeah
right I know then we were all yeah
anyway suffice it to say like there was
a challenge that uh um Aqua was
like she had a goal of trying to like if
if I were to wet my pants because it's
something was so funny on screen that
like she she was always trying to trying
to push that and um but anyway all of
that came out of that kind of
conversation so talking to someone who
grew up on Billy Madison and walked
around all the time saying it's cool to
pee in your pants so like all of this
really registers very well for me right
now taking it into somewh more serious
Direction so clearly Aquafina and Sandra
work very very well together but can you
tell us something unique about each of
their approaches to their own work where
maybe it even calls something it calls
for something different from you as
their actor's director sure oh really
great question I mean with Sandra she
prepares like no one else and um she has
her own you know methods and inhabiting
her character and movement work and all
that I wish you were here to talk about
that um but I would say that uh it was
really interesting to watch her go into
detail about what is Jenny wearing what
does her makeup look like how long are
her lashes um you know what what's she
doing with her nails all those things
where you know it's like the your armor
you you put it on and then you go into
battle so um seeing her operate at that
level and just enjoying it so much um
that I thought was really useful trying
to get it right what are her T what are
Jenny's tattoos like um so she had like
an Asian Tinkerbell done it was kind of
or Asian fairy done I should say that
was that kind of idea and um so that's
kind of part of how she works and with
Aquafina I think um she tends to absorb
and really um think about uh like all
the the conversations that we had and
just absorbs everything but wants to see
what comes out on the day so they both
do their work but the way that ites
comes out um is a little bit different I
think Sandra is more um interested in in
rehearsal uh and Aquafina also like they
respect each other so much that there
were ways that I don't actually know on
another project if say Aqua work
slightly differently but here it just
felt very sympatico um the way that they
that they approached things and uh it
yeah and with Aquafina too especially
just trying to um allow her that room to
just make jokes and and order off the
menu yeah is there any particular scene
in this movie where you all found it
most challenging to find the pitch
perfect balance between laugh out loud
extreme comedy but also making sure that
their experiences still feel just
grounded enough sure actually there's
one scene that I think is one of my
favorites which is when they're in the
emergency room and uh there's a
dislocated wrist involved so very
physical humor there and uh Sandra also
wanted that that wrist to really be
flopping around so you know we start
with this uh broader humor and then it
goes to a place that's as serious as
we've gotten in the film so far and so
it was navigating that in that scene
there are just little bits of Silence
that we allow ourselves in that that
it's not really elsewhere in the film um
again up to that point and so um I would
say that that was one where just trying
to see are we getting these beats but
also allowing for the air where it
doesn't feel like two separate movies
stuck together and I thought that they
really pulled it off beautifully that is
such a good example that particular
scene now I must ask like literally
everything about the moment when an
auditions and she's tripping the entire
time because I was utterly delighted by
that sequence I guess my my first
question about that what would you say
is the biggest difference between how
you pictured that scene looking when you
first read it compared to what we get in
the finished film oh yeah that's the
thing about um visual effects is that um
it's amazing what can be done and
sometimes you're thinking oh I just hope
that they can do this and you describe
it and then as it comes along then you
get something like whoa that's even
better so I had the idea that I wanted
to split screen their experiences so we
have the both povs in one shot it's not
a classic split screen because they're
sitting in the same environment and
there um so I had the idea one side is
really colorful fluffy clouds you know
singing birds and on the other side it's
the Grim reality of the you know hotel
conference room and what uh our team
came up with was this kind of um Bubble
effect so it's like she's in a you know
a soap bubble an is in her happy world
and I just thought that was so cool if
you could pinpoint one particular design
detail that you know in the end makes
you go like wow I can't believe they let
us go that far with this which little
detail would it be oh gosh h i mean well
that they let us have three uh pug
puppies they were just like running all
over the place um yeah I don't know like
they were you know people I mean U our
our producers everybody was just really
supportive of pushing things where we
needed to and um yeah so I I think it
kind of um all felt like we were allowed
oh I like uh hearing that you had that
support behind you I also love um
highlighting the unexpected Magic One
confined onset so can you maybe give me
an example of a day when things weren't
going to plan you had to Pivot but in
the process you wound up finding some of
that unexpected magic and a scene came
out better off for it yeah I you know I
we needed more misfortunes on set to
answer this properly because actually we
had a very I mean it was a such a fun
shoot very very smooth but actually okay
so in the game show you know there's
that giant coin that that is spun and we
love the idea of like it's literally
just a coin flip but they turn it into
the biggest deal imaginable so that
thing was heavy and constructed to you
know to give the weight to this moment
and spinning of the coin and it falls
off and we're like oh crap like the
mechanism kind of got broken so those
were full days and we had a kind of PIV
so I can't remember exactly what we
pivoted to I just remember that
everybody was so uh cool about it and
that set with Jason schwarzman and will
frell and um everybody just you know
bantering about that there wasn't going
to be a wasted moment right okay can't
shoot the coin we can jump into this
everybody's ready and bring on the
snoring pug all of that we could pull it
together every every movie with a Pug is
like infinitely better than any other
movie that exists you know pugs are
perfect though because especially here
because all Mr Linguini you needed to do
was look
like asleep asleep or half dead and pugs
like they're really method they will sit
there the only problem is sometimes they
would a Crosby who played Mr Linguini
would just like start snoring nothing
you can do just got to live with it you
know the sweetest sound in the world
though I love it yeah all right I'll end
with some silly game show questions now
so I'm going to name a couple of game
shows that require contestants to have
Partners I want you to tell me which
member of the quiz lady cast you would
want to be your partner on that
particular show all right first one on
my list is The Amazing Race oh gosh
um oh let's see I would probably say um
oh i' I'd say Sandra because I I think
she would just yeah she she would be a
really good good partner she got that
energy and like I think she could get
that competitive drive going so okay I
would believe that all right next one up
is Who Wants To Be A Millionaire so
basically your phone a friend person oh
oh Jason schwarzman because he is a
treasure Trove of random information
like our first conversation was 45
minutes about the science of a fake
smile and uh he gave me a book about the
study of facial expression so like he
would know some stuff weed I want one
one example like what is one sign kind
of a fake smile well of course not
reaching the eyes but we went and we
were he was like I want to like what's
the Prototype of so we hung up and like
an hour later I'm like Jason I know who
it is it's Mark
Zuckerberg and if you Google it I mean
it's a little painful but it is like you
could just see it he's like trying so
yeah that was oh now we know what I'm
GNA be doing after this all right I have
to end on this one who would be your
partner for can't stop the quizzes show
it round oh
you know I would say it would probably
be it depends on which side I would be
on but I do think it would be really
funny if um if it were uh Holland Taylor
doing the guessing because she would
just be like I don't know what are you
doing get off the floor and uh you know
we would lose but it would be we would
we would win the audience Hearts I think
with that I would also come to watch
that so you have me to come and watch
your horror movie and to watch the two
of you play Shades oh my gosh we've done
so much good work here I know really and
you've done great work with quiz lady
huge congratulations it is absolutely
delightful put a big genuine smile on my
face the entire time oh yeah non non
Zuckerberg smile yes Sor only non
Zuckerberg smiles over here thank you so
much and congratulations thank you I
appreciate
that